i have a five-year-old girl and
is she your oldest she's my youngest
she's younger i've got two
okay um she's my youngest i got a 10
year old boy
and a five-year-old girl that's fun it's
super fun
and i my wife and i my wife's
was she graduated her pc before me we we
were so
so arrogant after our son like after a
couple of years we just thought everyone
else sucks at parenting we're geniuses
clearly we need to quit our jobs and go
teach people how to do this and then my
daughter came along and we realized we
have no idea what we were doing
right we just rolled the dice well on
the first round
what should i be doing now what can i be
doing this is me not professional this
is me coming to you humbly
what can i be doing right now to make
sure
or to at least put some breadcrumbs
along the way so that my daughter
can have as good a body image as good a
reflection image as possible i've heard
everything from it's the
it's the dad's responsibility to make
sure
your daughter grows up healthy i've
heard that it's that all she will do is
watch my wife's
um the way my wife um
uh processes her own image and she'll
i've heard everything in between tell me
something i
or something a few things i can do right
now to instill that in here
well i don't know that i would say i
wouldn't probably land in either place
black and white i am yeah so i mean i
think
i think to think about food as fuel
okay obviously to talk about strength
instead of ever talking about weight i
mean i
i have so many i've had so many moms
over the years who are critical of
their daughter's bodies and i have never
i mean i jokingly say i've never had a
girl who says
my mom told me i need to lose some
weight and she says let me get on that
you know
you remember it backfires every time
and so i think as a dad i mean i think
i definitely think it's great to tell
her she's beautiful inside and out that
you're talking about
all of where beauty comes from in her
and that it's really
resonating inside of her more than
anything and that flows outward
but i think too you as a dad have this
i think as women were so intense and i
think as men you
have this ability to have a
light-heartedness and help them move
toward risk-taking
in a way that is challenging but in a
playful tone
okay and so i think when she learns that
she's
capable and strong and she can step into
things with you that are out of her
comfort zone i think
that capability and competence are i
think
linked to self-image and even body image
i think it all
just runs together yes yes so i think
speaking to the strengths of who she is
and helping grow her confidence
and an ability in a way that's very
unique to who you are as a man
how do you grow a kid's confidence
besides
letting them try and fail
it seems to be the the link right yeah i
can't i can't just tell them
right but but you do that too right i
mean i think it's both i mean they're
gonna roll their eyes and she's gonna
say you have to say that because you're
my dad
but i i would say say it anyway okay you
know i
one of my i have a friend who is really
confident probably one of the most
confident women i know and we were at a
dinner party one time and she said
that when she was growing up every time
she walked down the stairs of her home
like every time no matter how she was
dressed her dad whistled the theme song
to miss america
oh wow isn't that awesome which i mean
she was never in a pageant in her whole
life but i love that he was saying
when you walk in the room i'm going to
stop and pay attention to you yep
and i think just that level of
engagement even plays into her
confidence in a really significant way
and that's not
taking her on some elaborate date no
it's just the little things yeah
i notice that my kids from
however different they are they both if
i were to distill
them down into one sentence it one one
question it would be
please see me and that seems to be the
most pervasive
overarching thing about their behavior
whether my son is trying to get straight
a's my daughter's trying to set
something on fire
or vice versa right it is please see me
right and if i every time i can jump the
front of the line and make sure they
know before they even have to
perform yeah i see you just because
you're you right
it just seems the the air in the room
gets lighter right